en un vídeo anterior hablamos sobre
externalidades en este caso las
externalidades asociadas a tener bolsas
de plástico que causan basura que pueden
dañar el ambiente y estábamos asumiendo
en ese vídeo asumimos que podíamos
calcular el costo externo real asociado
a esto que es de 2 centavos por bolsa
ese es el costo del impacto en la basura
y en el medio ambiente después
encontramos que si aplicamos factoraje y
en lugar de tener nuestra curva del
costo marginal agregamos esto a esta
curva de costos si lo agregamos al costo
externo tendríamos el mercado de la
oferta más el costo externo y
encontraríamos un nuevo punto de
equilibrio el costo y la cantidad óptima
para producir de las bolsas de plástico
y así evitamos caer en este superávit
negativo que es cuando el costo total de
las bolsas es mayor que la ganancia de
estas bolsas pero una cosa que no vimos
en el vídeo anterior es cómo hacer que
suceda esto
si nosotros dejáramos las cosas como son
y dejáramos la curva anterior del costo
marginal de la oferta y también
dejáramos la curva del consumidor o de
la demanda el precio de equilibrio
estaría aquí ya que en este momento no
estaríamos considerando los costos
externos asociados a las bolsas de
plástico
si ustedes fueran un gobernante benévolo
en esta sociedad qué harían ustedes para
acercar la cantidad a este otro punto de
equilibrio de acá en donde ya se toma en
cuenta este costo externo hay varias
opciones a elegir acá uno podrían
prohibir la producción de bolsas de
plástico prohibir las bolsas de plástico
otra es poner una cuota a las bolsas de
plástico es decir no se puede producir
más de cierta cantidad de bolsas de
plástico o se puede poner un impuesto a
las bolsas de plástico poner un impuesto
a las bolsas de plástico ahora
analicemos cada una de estas opciones
para ver cuál de ellas produce el
superávit que de más beneficios a la
sociedad y una asunción básica qué vamos
a hacer aquí es asumir que este costo es
real si nosotros simplemente
prohibiéramos las bolsas de plástico o
este emperador benévolo de esta sociedad
decide prohibir estas bolsas de plástico
qué pasaría en este caso este mercado
simplemente no existiría y todo este
superávit que podría existir ya no
existiría más por lo que en este caso
estaríamos destruyendo un superávit
ustedes no pueden decir no es que estas
bolsas de plástico son horrendas
deberían de dejar de existir no hay
ningún beneficio que valga la pena de
ellas pero no sé acaso ustedes estarían
argumentando este punto de acá que el
costo no es de dos centavos por bolsa
sino de diez centavos por bolsa como
ésta en realidad negativa y debido a
esto esta curva la tendremos desplazada
hacia arriba todavía más y no existiría
alguna cantidad posible que existiera
para obtener un beneficio de ellas pero
ya
estamos seguros de que la externalidad
negativa es de 2 centavos por bolsa si
nosotros prohibiremos las bolsas de
plástico estaríamos eliminando ese
superávit de este mercado y ahora qué
sucede componer una cuota o un límite a
la producción de bolsas de plástico
vemos este estudio de acá y encontramos
que la cantidad óptima de bolsas de
plástico a producir es de 1.9 millones
por semana esa es la cantidad máxima que
debe de producir el mercado cuando
hacemos esto asumimos que de verdad
comprendemos lo que significa esta curva
de demanda cuando elegimos ese tipo de
opciones porque realmente comprendemos
totalmente lo que significa esa curva de
costos y entonces esta serie hemos
asumido que de verdad comprendemos ambas
cosas pero en el mundo real es muy
difícil conocer exactamente cómo luce la
curva del costo marginal de igual manera
es muy difícil conocer cuál es la curva
de demanda especialmente porque siempre
están cambiando aumentan los
competidores o disminuyen los
competidores hay más productos
sustitutos o hay cosas que se hacen más
eficientes o menos eficientes así que es
muy difícil conocer cuáles
hacer la verdadera cantidad de
equilibrio y precio de equilibrio por lo
que una cuota es bastante difícil de
implementar en la vida real finalmente
en la opción de los impuestos podemos
decir que bueno sin importar cómo es
realmente la curva de costos marginales
vamos simplemente desplazarla por dos
centavos eso lo vimos cuando hablamos de
impuestos y cuando hablamos por primera
vez de impuestos introdujimos el
concepto de pérdida de peso muerto
cuando hablamos de producir cierta
cantidad que no se consume en este caso
un impuesto podría prevenir la pérdida
del peso muerto porque si tenemos un
impuesto de dos centavos estamos
esencialmente agregando el costo de la
externalidad negativa en forma de un
impuesto por encima del costo de la
oferta y de esta manera vamos a
ocasionar que la cantidad de equilibrio
se desplace para no generar todo ese
superávit negativa y aquí tenemos un
efecto secundario positivo y de nuevos
unimos que esto es el número correcto
pero podríamos tener un efecto
secundario positivo en donde estemos
generando algún beneficio para él
en la opción del impuesto no tenemos que
saber cómo luce la curva del costo
marginal o como luce la curva de demanda
siempre y cuando asumamos que esta es la
cantidad correcta el impuesto siempre va
a desplazar la curva sin importar qué
forma tenga este e interceptar a la
curva de demanda cualquiera que ésta sea
en el punto de equilibrio que estamos
buscando dándonos un precio de
equilibrio y una cantidad de equilibrio
si ese es el número correcto lo usamos
para poner un impuesto en las bolsas de
plástico dos centavos de impuesto por
bolsa y probablemente esta sea la mejor
opción en términos de optimizar el
superávit total